Here's everything we ate
during our last morning in New York.
We wanted to start off the day by getting bagels,
so we went to Tompkins Square Bagels,
and honestly,
I was so disappointed
they didn't get our orders right,
and my bagel was so toasted
that I genuinely couldn't eat it.
So we went to Joe's Pizza right after
because we needed some food in our system.
Got the cheese slice,
the pepperoni slice,
and then lucky got sausage and onion.
This was actually really good.
We ended up having about five slices each,
and then heading to this Swedish candy shop.
I'm obsessed with any red candies,
so my whole bag was pretty much red
apart from Lucky's candy.
Got him all the watermelon flavored things
because that's his favorite flavor.
Stopped by this candy shop on the way to the bakery,
and then headed over to Supermoon Bakehouse.
Couldn't decide on what to get,
so lucky just insisted
I get all the stuff that I've been eyeing,
so I did exactly that.
We headed back to the hotel,
and lucky made me try this nostalgic candy to him,
which was absolutely vile.
I wanted to be a good sport.
I started off with this Thai tea eclair,
which was so good.
It wasn't too sweet,
it was perfectly creamy.
And then I had this matcha croissant,
which, honestly,
and blow me away,
so it wasn't worth mentioning,
but this passion fruit
custard filled doughnut was absolutely divine.